all right here we are it's Sunday
hopefully you guys have seen Star Wars
or less Jedi because my Star Wars the
last Jedi spoiler talk there are some
spoilers in here don't watch this unless
you've seen it I know there's no Star
Wars curtain cape I've reserved the
curtain cape for those moments of fan
boy is or I could just fanboy out and
have fun with it go back to my childhood
is when we did not bring me back to my
childhood there are things I want to
address it you want to get real with you
and to be honest with you I'm glad I saw
the movie again because in my spoiler
free review I was like this is one of
those movies where I need to watch it
twice before I really process this thing
but the things that pissed me off still
pissed me off but there are things in
this movie that are great I like those
great things like the beginning action
sequence in this movie oh Dameron is in
fact a great pilot and that guy's a
commander on the Dreadnought ship he was
a dick he was the best dude look like
George see Scotty just had a scout like
of course my god this guy hearkened back
to old school Empire in fact if you can
trade him out with Hawks I'd be fine
with that yeah at this point Huck's just
kind of annoys me because he screams all
the time though he did that in the force
awakens I thought there was room for
growth apparently there's not so yeah
let's bring that dude into the fold I
feel like that dude would do some
straight damage he's dead now though so
I guess we won't get him but I like the
Poe Dameron calls him the bombers that
drop bombs in space because this is
gravity I know tie bombers have already
existed but I always thought tie bombers
as they shoot something but just
vertically down it's not gravity that
does it is actually shooting something
down it's how I always saw it anyway but
a lot of people die in here so I like
the fact where is this like dude you
can't just blow everything up sometimes
you just got to run cuz it's like 50 of
us is we're not big then we see Ray
going to Luke now this is one of those
things where she holds Luke's lightsaber
to Luke Luke grabs it and the way the
music was going I was like he's gonna
shitcan that thing over his shoulder
totally dead throws right over his
shoulder which is pretty much a metaphor
for any and all fan theories and
expectations for those movies but that
was the first thing I was like did you
rip them I mean really look at it this
is Anakin Skywalker's lightsaber Luke
Skywalker had that lightsaber when he
fought his father his father cut his
hand off it fell down a chasm in a Cloud
City by all rights he should never have
seen that thing again but here is four
decades later in front of his face and
he's not even the least bit curious it's
not like where did you get this
even Han Solo asked Maz Kanata where she
got it which we're probably never gonna
find out maybe in the books so he just
Chuck's it over his shoulder I felt like
was a moment where just like that could
have been a serious moment and they just
sacrificed that for an unexpected laughs
it is very Disney a fight of them so I
just kind of like uh is it gonna all be
like that it's not all like that but
moments like that are in it but I really
do like the Rey Luke dynamic in this
movie there's a good lesson in there
about heroes versus reality
legends versus the person at one point
Luke is talking about Darth Vader and
raised like you're the Jedi who saved me
was like and I became a legend Luke
Skywalker is the whole like don't meet
your hero saying because heroes are not
the reality of the situation they're not
the person and yet heroes are just
people and people are in fact flawed I
really hated that whole casino planet
thing in fact I hated the whole arc with
Finn Rose I didn't like any of it
because you look at it Finn's like
they're tracking us through hyperspace
which has happened in Battlestar
Galactica but the first order can track
them through hyperspace so there is a
hyperspace trackers so they need to go
to this stupid casino planet find a
hacker get him back into the ship so
they can hack it so they can't find them
when they jump into hyperspace they
can't be tracked and in the end they go
to this planet meet Benicio del Toro who
is not the hacker they were looking for
but he is a hacker nonetheless who kind
of talks like Roger Rabbit then they go
back to Snoke ship to Hackett and they
don't end up hacking it at all so really
the whole thing was just completely
useless how about this since you have
Rose a character no one really knows
about it how about one Finn's like oh
they're tracking us through hyperspace
they're going back and forth and they
kind of get the tech Finn can get them
there because he mopped the floors and
maybe Rose is actually a really good
hacker so let's say Finn and Rose just
go there and there are constructive
being on that Cocina planet is actually
in Snoke ship trying to be stealthy may
be running into some conflict Randa that
would be a lot like the Death Star also
the star killer base arc with Han Chewie
Finn but I think it would be more
interesting than that Casino planet
actually give Rose more relevance cut
out this segment entirely and maybe be
relevant because maybe they'll actually
hack it doesn't change the fact that you
wouldn't need a hack because in the end
the first order just follows them down
to the salt planet no need to track
through hyperspace at all because there
is no saving that are created the
illusion of relevance for the hacker
comes from when the resistance is
sneaking down to the salt planet he's
the one who was like hey they're
sneaking down in the salt planet so then
they start picking them off because they
were gonna be cloaked before or you can
have a scenario where they're all on
that ship that like we're out of gas
they're gonna blow us up our best chance
is to go down to the salt plant I know
the first order just sees it happen no
need
hacker - betrayal I mean I get what they
were doing with the casino planet war
profiteering rich people getting rich on
the backs of other people we core people
people get screwed by them and animal
cruelty basically it's just kind of a
lens on our civilization as seen in the
Star Wars world if you're going to
address a social issue just at least
make it a good storyline I just don't
see things like that I don't see like
other social issue that that makes it
good I just see a plot point that sticks
out like a sore thumb which is such a
tragedy because John boyega is so
charismatic when he's going to that
escape pod and he's gonna go get ray
which is like I had to zap people escape
and he's like that's just disgraceful
looks like he's so good why would you
waste him in this fashion and then when
you bring on a new character like Rose
why would you waste her why not make her
the hackers you would have been more
relevant than how it's done I guess it
throw down with phasma happens really
quick fight that then ends has been
bashes her over the face with that stick
that they were gonna kill him with and
she calls him scum he says rebel scum
she falls down into a fiery pit yes
she's dead again might not be I imagine
she's dead but I will say they go out of
their way to show that her armor can
deflect blaster bolts so if it is heat
resistant and possibly impact resistant
like vibranium
I'm literally making [ __ ] up I'm just
saying what if it's a sci-fi adventure
let's say she falls through the fire at
lids gets into a pod now she says could
be in the next one I don't know point is
why bring her back - just kill her again
it's like they were like okay phasma
didn't get her shine before so now she's
gonna get her not shine again but maybe
phasma is just useless we're really
trying though and in the end the Finn
and Rose thing which I didn't even see
it as a romance until she saves him from
that big battering ram thing at the end
which I guess is miniaturise death star
tech which I don't know why it has to be
miniaturised death star attack nothing
about it really reminded me of the Death
Star all the way it shot its laser
didn't remind me had the Death Star gun
are we to believe a Kyber crystals in
that thing what's a Death Star about it
why not just say it's a big battering
ram that's gonna crack this thing like
an egg that'd be flying anyhow when he's
going towards it though I was like dude
Finn's dead he's going to die today at
that point I was really oh man Oh
emotional hmm and then Rose saves him
and Finn goes over the life that was
done what he's you she's like I saved
you dumb it's how we're gonna win not by
fighting the things we hate but saving
the things we love this she does this
kiss his awkward kiss where he's just
staring at her it was almost like an
impromptu kiss I feel like John boyega
look lucky he wasn't even expecting they
were like that takes perfect it's good
that was a good kiss oh it looked like
she kissed her brother just did but even
in
are words that can work and have some
passion I'm just saying the moment they
flipped that thing from a completely
useless storyline story arc in the movie
so completely forced and terrible
romance I was like is that the worst
romance I've seen in Star Wars possibly
yeah I'm saying possibly at least Anakin
and Padme look like a couple of young
people who wanted to bang I just don't
buy these two I don't lay a goes into a
coma in the movie which is funny because
I heard she was a huge part of this
movie but she goes into a coma
it's a hull breach kylo Ren calms he's
gonna waste Leia and he's like nah and a
couple of Thai fighters just shoot the
bridge and suck all of the commanders
out and then she does like the Mary
Poppins thing there's a force bubble
that comes around her after she's all
frozen so they're not forcing the bird
that actually kind of reminded me of old
Star Wars lore like now it's legends but
before the prequels came out the story
was Anakin fell into a volcano and the
lava was burning him and he created a
force bubble where he just stayed alive
so it kind of reminded me of that is
ultimately a force bubble that keeps
someone alive in an environment that
should kill them point is more
commanders we all grew up with her dead
now now we're gonna talk about Laura
Dern's character her name is I think a
whole dog she just kind of came across
in the movie as an [ __ ] who should
not be in charge granted I know Poe
Dameron really screwed up and he got
reprimanded by Leia he is feeling the
burn a lot of people died dude made a
dumb call shouldn't have done it
absolutely throw me in the brig if you
feel like you need to do it guys
straight up [ __ ] up and people died
however right when Poe goes to hold on
he was like hey we just want to know
what the plan is what's going on she's
like I know you you're the one Leia
demoted right yeah you're a flyboy
you're a hothead you're the last thing
we need she literally just opened it up
for conflict I just don't feel like
that's what a good leader does then for
the rest of the movie he's literally
like we're all gonna die can you please
tell us the plan and she doesn't she
doesn't tell him the plan why didn't you
tell him does she think Poe dameron's a
spy does she think she's surrounded by
spies in a moment like this where a
character keeps secrets from another
character for no good reason I feel like
they're keeping secrets from us the
audience I just have to write away for
it to happen
these comes across like she has [ __ ]
communication she's not doing it for the
fleet she's doing it for pride she
doesn't like this guy this guy's a dick
she's not gonna tell him anything yes
this is a military operation the
commanders don't have to tell everybody
everything but he kind of encompasses
one twentieth of the fleet you have left
so I feel like a little communication
would be pretty good I just feel like
the best leaders I've ever known in real
life and fiction just have good
communication with their subordinates
you could just feel like
right here's the plan we're just gonna
try to outrun them we're gonna get in
the pods they won't be able to see us
with the radar we're gonna go to that
planet we're gonna hold up and be safe
it's what we got you know what it works
because when leia told it to po he was
like oh cool yeah we're so the whole
conflict was born of the fact that they
both wanted to establish dominance above
each other it led to a mutiny which was
also in Battlestar Galactica just the
whole thing came across as like
everybody's a dick I think Leia should
reprimand all of you when she comes out
of her coma however she does lead to the
most visually glorious moment in the
entire possibly in the entire Star Wars
saga
that's scene where she goes into
hyperspace through the ship and just
splits all the ships into that [ __ ] was
business sound cuts out it's a black and
white yep love that however I will argue
in a world where it looks like the new
way of Star Wars is introduced new
characters kill off all the old ones
introduce new ones kill them off kill
off some more old ones introduce new
ones kill them off I feel like an end
like that alright here you go
hypothetical situation Admiral Ackbar
has been a hero in the rebellion for
decades if Admiral Ackbar had met that
end would that be more satisfying for me
yes much better than blowing him out of
a hull breach like they did all the
command gone if he's the one who did the
kamikaze run I just would have felt
fullfillment least they sent one of the
old characters off well with the race
lineage thing I'm not gonna lie there
were two knee-jerk reactions where I was
like well that was useless setup who
were raised parents and who is Snoke
watching it a second time I've ironed
him out here are my thoughts on it I
like the poetry in the fact that rey
comes from nothing because really a lot
of great people don't come from
greatness they come from the mud that
makes them mighty that makes them great
i guess the force chose her because
they're stronger kylo Ren gets then his
equal will be matched in the light which
is Rey which begs the question is that
how it is when someone gets stronger in
the dark side does the light match it
does it work with vice versa so when all
those Jedi were just kind of ruling the
galaxy the two sit that we're doing rule
of two were they super powerful because
they had to contest with the power of
about 10,000 Jedi I don't know it
doesn't really explain it but I do enjoy
the prospect that she does come from
nothing though I do feel like the force
awakens did beg the question where does
she come from it's kind of a rope adult
kind of scenario gonna touch on that a
bit more after we talked about snoke's
not [ __ ] dies that's just the way it
goes
kylo ren's straight-up just turns the
lightsaber it strikes it rips him in
half he's [ __ ] dead although Darth
Maul
in half fell down a pit he lived but
that did lead to an epic team-up
lightsaber fight not a lightsaber fight
lightsaber fight when they're taking
down those Praetorian guards satisfying
one guess it is so anything is this is
the first numbered Star Wars movie
without EDD lightsaber on lightsaber
fight here's my take on the Snoke thing
is that it's not disappointing that we
were all like weird of Snoke come from
Oh we'd never find out so now it's
useless it's not I do believe a
character is determined by what they do
not where they come from so if you never
know where they come from you can at
least see what they do but Snoke didn't
do anything that's the problem Snoke had
two very quick scenes in this movie and
then he just died I know they wanted to
make phasma the new Boba Fett and she's
really not no snoke's closer to Boba
Fett actually Boba Fett got more he
actually did more before he died in a
stupid as death and that's how Snoke
went out he got Boba Fett it now it's
the term should be he got snow seeing
Return of the Jedi Palpatine was a
presence he was always there you always
felt him he was a menace Vader went to
him kind of talked with him a couple
times went back got Luke that
throne-room dynamic is amazing but
Palpatine had a lot of shine he did a
lot of [ __ ] Snoke had two scenes he
didn't really do [ __ ] and it's like with
Rey and who her parents are both
theories were blown out of proportion by
fans myself included I apologize for
that but I would argue when the force
awakens sets up Rey go now my family
they'll be back it puts the question in
fans Minds like well who's her family
then you see a force flash back of the
ship flying away and she's a little girl
getting dragged away it's like who's her
family the force awakens set up the
question of who's her family didn't have
to be like oh yeah your parents were
garbage every junk traders he just
traded you for some money it kind of
feels like Andy Kaufman directed this
movie like I'll be great I'll be a
practical joke we'll just Punk the
entire world and that whole who is Snoke
thing I mean you have a character with a
twisted ass body and a messed up face
like I said in my review of the force
awakens that guy's face has a story what
happened to him how did it get messed up
like that that begs the question who is
he why show a story on his face if
you're not really gonna fulfill that
I'll answer you're gonna see it
fulfilled in the books and I feel like
that's the problem with multiple
directors taking on this new trilogy you
have one director who sets things up for
the next movie or the trilogy as a whole
and then the next strike just like now
I'm just gonna kind of cut that off and
concentrate on this and then wrap up the
story good luck on the third one Abrams
it shows how writers and directors kind
of want to go their own way
when telling the story that doesn't
really coincide with the setup of the
previous story that it's Star Wars
people will watch it it'll make money
doesn't matter I mean it's the immortal
battle of expectation versus reality for
those movies in the world were for the
prequels George Lucas said we would
learn how anakin got the name darth
vader and what darth vader means and why
jedi disappear when they die and they
turn into force ghosts and we didn't get
either of those I mean if that was
underwhelming you have to at least humor
the idea that this is also gonna be
underwhelming but that's just for fan
speculation why it pissed off Star Wars
fans just kind of giving you the fact of
the matter as I see it so it's really
the perception of the matter the reality
of the situation for Snoke is just when
I started to get interested in the guy
in this movie he died and that just did
why why even have him he's now a plot
device for setup for kylo Ren arrays arc
in the movie is really funny because she
goes to this island to learn from Luke
and Luke's like I'm gonna tell you the
ways of the Jedi and why they need to
end so those are the lessons here's the
force and she's feeling the force and
he's like can you feel the forces like
yes I feel the light the dark everything
you see like a bunch of clips plants
growing that was a really cool moment
and looks like the force doesn't belong
to the Jedi
it belongs to everything to say that
it's exclusive to the Jedi is vanity do
you see that Oh My gods a very good case
you're making and I do agree with you
Luke and that's why the Jedi need to end
because of that vanity Luke was making
such a great case about the Jedi having
to end I was totally on board so when he
was wrong I guess I was wrong too with
that vision the Luke says you were
pulled to the darkness you didn't even
fight it she was like it was trying to
show me something he was like I've only
seen this natural power one other time
and Ben solo it didn't scare me enough
then it does now and he walks off
they're like okay she's like straight up
naturally powerful being pulled to the
darkness which doesn't really play out
because she's never really pulled to the
darkness at no point is she like yeah
totally I'm feeling pretty dark right
now no points does the darkness actually
tempt her even when kylo Ren tells her
later on like join me she's like don't
do this never it never comes into play
it just kind of builds up this darkness
that never really goes anywhere I do
like the perspective thing of kylo Ren
and Luke and what happened in that huh I
mean Luke Skywalker when he's first
telling the stories like I was like no
Ben and Ben solo just pulled the roof
down on me and kylo ren's like no here's
how it happened he struck his light
saber you look so evil like I'm gonna
kill you and he tried to kill me and
when I heard both sides I was like the
reality of the situation is probably
very much in between and it was it was
in between Luke Skywalker for a moment
was like
read his mind he's really bad turned on
the lightsaber maybe I'll kill him then
was like that was fleeting and then I
felt shame and then kylo Ren woke up it
was like oh he's trying to kill me so
like perception is reality kind of
moment but I kinda I don't buy that I
get the tragedy that Luke Skywalker with
one fleeting action created kylo Ren
ultimately Kiley was like ah nope out
[ __ ] tried to kill me I'm gonna waste
of school but like I don't see a world
where someone's going to be like I read
my nephew's Minds up he's bad so I'm
going to kill him right now I don't get
that wouldn't you talk to your sister
before thinking about murdering her
child your sister and your friend like
hey guys I think we should have an
intervention there's some dark things
happening in his mind maybe we can show
him something I mean I just don't get a
world where Luke even for that long it's
like I'm going to kill him and he thinks
about it long enough to pop out his
lightsaber and turn it on it's all I got
that just passed his mind it's like a
thought that provokes like at least
three forms of action like one two
strikes I just don't I don't buy that I
don't see it he's gonna burn the tree
with the texts in them and Yoda's there
where Yoda was awesome it was puppet
Yoda baby I I do yes I loved it it
really it was Yoda straight-up Yoda that
I remember from Empire Strikes Back who
can call a bolt of lightning down and he
just wastes the tree and burns it looks
like oh dude you're just like I read
them have your page turners David he's
pretty much like there's nothing in
there that Ray's fine without the book
so later it shows that Ray stole the
book so - Yoda knows she stole the books
I really got a lot of resolution with
Yoda and Luke watching this tree burn it
really did feel like the Jedi are to end
they had their time now it's like a new
generation of things then ray keeps the
books and now Luke's not going to be the
last Jedi Ray's going to be they're
gonna be more Jedi out there so the Jedi
are just coming back and when you bring
a force ghost into a Star Wars story and
show what a force ghost can do though
they're not really ghosted you have mass
Yoda bonks Luke on the nose sits on a
rock so when lb-1 kenobi got tired and
sat on that log makes sense but he also
called both a lightning out of the sky
to burn a tree so can all force ghosts
do that did they only show up to force
users so they don't show up to the good
guys look at the end when he faced off
against kylo Ren said see you around kid
and then Luke disappeared so I guess
he's not gonna see him around the only
way he could see him around is if he
shows up to him as a forest ghost in
which case can you just call a lightning
bolt out of the sky just [ __ ] kill
him and then I have to wonder why is it
Luke's dad Anakin around as a force
ghost I would love to see Luke and
can have some father-son time make up
for some lost time don't none of that he
just gets Yoda well that's fair I like
seeing you Opie ones just kind of a
catalyst that got him into it but they
all showed up at the end party of Return
of the Jedi
maybe Anakin can go to kylo Ren and be
like you're being a dick stop it stop it
all it's gonna lead to misery I used to
think I knew how force ghosts worked and
then under the Disney regime the force
powers just always changing all the time
so in the end of the movie they have all
the walkers and Luke shows up and just
like everything stops Luke walks out
there and kylo Ren just lights him up
and a barrage it's funny because the red
salt makes it look like blood so it was
a boom I was like did he die he did Luke
lives through die like he's just like
kylo Ren goes down there to face him and
I'm not gonna lie I didn't even notice
it hi Lorraine moves his foot on the
ground it turns red Luke moves his foot
nothing is just white Luke has the wrong
lightsaber he has his dad's lightsaber
that he is so emotionally attached to
that he chucked it over his shoulder at
the beginning of the movie and he faces
off against kylo Ren and just dodges all
his [ __ ] he's buying time he needs the
rebels to get out of there all ten of
them that are left in kylo Ren swipes
through should kill him nope he doesn't
disappear and you push the saber through
his chest it's like he's like he's not
there you see Luke meditating on that
rock just floating like he's some sort
of Monk
I was pretty slick dude I'm not gonna
lie it was pretty good he bought them an
ample amount of time Luke collapses and
then disappears and looks like say
around kid which is the biggest slap
across the face ever and then Luke
disappeared he dies I guess or becomes
one with the force ray says she felt a
feeling of peace when he passed but why
how did he pass why did he pass did he
just become one with the force and not
die in the way we see death when I first
thought I was like what does he like
spawn does they have a finite amount of
force points and when they're all gone
he just disappears and the force kill
you if you use it too much has anyone
ever done that in the history of Star
Wars I guarantee you in the Republic
there was some straight-up Grand Jedi
Masters out there who could have done
that [ __ ] people like just done spy
missions in the Clone Wars maybe I don't
know maybe the darkside was everywhere
and they couldn't do it it really does
open a lot of doors of speculation as to
you how powerful is that who can do it
why didn't do it before see the more you
expand on forest powers more you add to
force powers and these are powers that
have always been around and always been
available you make more plot holes
looking back at what's happened at those
moments where no one used those powers
and totally could've you're like where
are they gonna go now we know now kylo
Ren is bad and he's running the first
order and he's either
gonna turn good in the end or get killed
either ones fine I don't really I'm not
invested in either one because the
family dynamics gone now this is the
story of the Skywalker's we've heard it
so many times it's not really a story of
the Skywalker's there's one living
Skywalker that's kylo Ren that's not
really their fault Carrie Fisher
untimely past and you can see she
probably was gonna have a huge part in
the next movie because she is the last
link and kylo Ren so hell-bent on wiping
out his past at this point I do humor
the ideas like maybe they should recast
laughs that or the fact that she's just
she's going to wrap up her arc they're
going to kill her in a book
Rey go into kylo Ren to turn him it
doesn't make any sense to me she saw a
possible future for kylo Ren sure but I
do know that she called him a murderer
she called him a monster she did not
care about his Redemption until she saw
him without his shirt and she was like
maybe I can help sit on your force I
mean face I mean I mean help you with
the force so put on a towel it makes me
miss do so I hope there's not a romance
there because I just don't to say it how
did Snoke link kylo Ren and raise minds
when he didn't know who Raven was only
knew about Rey is that there was a
scavenger who beat kylo Ren in a fight I
don't know what she looks like he
doesn't even know her name he doesn't
know her location that's for sure if he
knew that he'd find Luke maybe he
gleaned kylo ren's mind and saw his
memory of her that's still just it's a
memory of her I don't think you can find
where they are based on a memory of
where they were make some sense when you
really realize he does not know Rey at
all I do love that sweet moment when
luke skywalker sees r2d2 and he's like
hurt too it's that moment Reese's r2 and
smiles I was like oh he's like a kid
again because he saw something that
reminded him of his youth and he's right
back there he says r2 there's nothing
you can do to change my mind and then r2
shows him that holographic recording of
Leia from the original Star Wars that
was good that put a smile on my face
even though kind of broke my heart and
then he winks at c-3po when you see you
soon because Luke is the only one who
ever treated c-3po with any form of
dignity the only one who was ever nice
to him I just his shows as zooms in to
c-3po faizal's like yeah I'd hit golden
rod right in his golden heart some of
the humor in this movie is strange to
Star Wars movies aren't foreign to humor
but this movie does have humor that's
very 2017 humor that's was jarring about
it straight up when poe dameron at the
beginning of the movie gets on the
intercom with Huck's he straight-up does
can you hear me now good that's
cellphone humor they've never had
cellphones we've never seen cellphone
humor though it is a little jarring and
poor guys I meant to sell toys for white
why are they in here we're cute yeah
they taste like chicken sure all the
pork hype do
like why the why are they here I know
why they're here but why are they here
but in the end there was a lot to like
about this movie this movie is gorgeous
looking a lot of times I feel like
people are like if the movie looked
gorgeous that's enough it's not for me
not for a Star Wars film I I need the
characters to be done justice I need the
plot to make sense need to not waste
people's time sometimes this movie did
that but it was still entertaining and
enjoyable to watch I know I really
hammered home the problems but the
problems are important to address a good
movie can have problem I'm just saying
things that are flawed but enjoyable
things that have flaws they're fine and
that's how I see the last Jedi
I certainly give it a good time no
alcohol required for a guy so Star Wars
the last Jedi have you seen it now what
did you think about it do you enjoy it
do you not is it a good Star Wars movie
is it a fine sci-fi movie is it neither
for you whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]